compromise is cheaper than divorce so
that is something to consider yeah wow
see the LA Times didn't say that
I like it Joey and I obviously went
through our own renovation and that I've
never shared the design element of my
own home with somebody before and I was
petrified that we were going to get into
like a conflict because we don't like we
are like the yin and yang to each other
we're perfectly balanced she has
Exquisite taste it was a dream I let her
run with like a lot of the finishes she
picked the tile and the hardware and I
worked on the architectural stuff and we
did not have a bilingual fight it's
dividing conquering based on your skills
and what's fun for you she has a great
design eye as well but you really love
the architectural side of it you know
the the ownership couple you we always
say who uses the kitchen space a little
bit more who uses the home office a
little bit more let that person have the
final say and there are more than one
right way to do things it's going to be
fine as long as they have the final say
we've found every couple has made it
through and they both end up liking the
home in the end